We all know the story of Mowgli
from Rudyard Kipling's
"The Jungle Book",
about the boy
who was brought up by wolves.
Or Edgar Rice Burrough's Tarzan,
who was raised by chimpanzees.
And there's the story
of Romulus and Remus,
the founders of Rome,
suckled by a wolf in a cave.
Eww.
But can humans really
be raised by animals?
And if so, how would
they adapt to society?
Feral children are children who
don't have interactions
with other humans.
There are about 4,000 accounts
of feral children that
are considered reliable.
Sadly, most of these cases
are due to neglect.
Here are three incredible stories
of humans raised by animals.
This is Marina Chapman.
In 2012, she published a book
about being raised by monkeys
in the jungles of Columbia.
In 1950, when she was a young child,
Chapman was abandoned in a forest.
She almost died until a family
of capuchin monkeys
led her to fruit and nuts.
The monkeys took her in
and protected her.
But she still had to fend for herself,
taking food when she could.
When she was about nine years old,
she was discovered by people
who, sadly, sold her
into domestic slavery.
She ran away and lived on the streets,
where she learned to speak
and used her jungle skills to survive.
Eventually, she was able to
conform to modern society
and even married and had children.
This is Marcos Pantoja.
After losing his mother at an early age,
Marcos suffered an abusive upbringing
from his stepmother.
At the age of six, his father
sold him to a goat farmer
in a remote area
of the Sierra Morena mountain range
in Spain.
When the farmer died two years later,
Marcos was left to fend for himself.
While exploring the mountains for food,
Marcos came across
a wolf cub in a cave.
After playing with the cub, he fell asleep
and woke later to find the mother
growling and baring her teeth at him.
Marcos backed away.
After feeding her cubs,
the mother offered some of
the leftover meat to the boy.
From then on,
Marcos lived as a member
of the wolfpack for 12 years.
He was found by Spanish Civil Guards,
who bound and gagged him
to keep him from howling.
They took him home to his father.
Wanting nothing to do with Marcos,
his father took him to a hospital
run by nuns.
There he was taught to speak,
walk upright,
dress properly,
and eat with cutlery.
The feral upbringing
left Marcos traumatized.
He fought with the nuns
when they tried to get him
to sleep in a bed.
And he feared he was being attacked
during his first haircut.
After serving in the military
and working with a pastor
for many years,
Marcos struggled to adapt
to modern society.
Feeling isolated,
he returned to the mountains
to live with the animals.
Unfortunately, his wolf family
rejected him
because of his human scent.
This is Oxana Malaya.
In 1991, at the age of three,
she was left outside
by her alcoholic parents.
She crawled into a dog kennel
for shelter and warmth.
Oxana spent the next five years
with the dogs, where she ate scraps
left by the animals.
A neighbor noticed her at eight years old
living in the kennel.
She ran on all fours,
barked like a dog,
panted with her tongue out
and would bare her teeth.
She couldn't talk.
"Can't talk."
Once a child passes the age of five
without learning to talk,
it is almost impossible for them
to learn to speak normally.
"Can you say hello?"
Oxana, however, did speak
before she was abandoned
and was able to relearn
how to communicate.
It took six months to suppress
her dog-like behavior.
Now an adult, she is able to speak
and eats with her hands instead of
lapping up her food with her tongue.
But she still has moments
when she goes back
to her feral upbringing,
like crawling on all fours
when she feels lonely.
It is estimated that she has
the mental capacity of a six-year-old.
Now that we've seen
that feral children are real,
we'll discover if humans
can have superpowers
on another episode of